>>> RUSSIAN AND UKRAINIANS FACE
A BATTLE FROM THE SKY.
>> Reporter: AT UKRAINE'S
SOUTHERN FRONT, RECONNAISSANCE
TEAM LEADS US TOWARD RUSSIAN
LINES.
WE ARE WALKING THROUGH THE TREES
BECAUSE THEY ARE AFRAID WE MIGHT
BE SPOTTED FROM ABOVE BY RUSSIAN
DRONES.
THAT IS THE WAY THEY DO THEIR
WORK OUT HERE.
HIDDEN BY THE TREES.
OUR DESTINATION, A DRONE TEAM
SHROUDED FROM THE SKIES.
THEIR MISSION, FIND RUSSIAN
FORCES AND CALL IN ARTILLERY
STRIKES.
A PROBLEM THOUGH ON THEIR FIRST
FLIGHT OF THE DAY.
RUSSIAN COUNTERMEASURES MESS
WITH THEIR DRONE.
THEY NEED TO SWITCH OUT PARTS
BEFORE THE NEXT LAUNCH.
IT IS NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO FIGHT
OFF THE RUSSIAN JAMMING SIGNAL
THE COMMANDER SAYS.
BUT WE HAVE SPECIAL DEVICES TO
COMBAT IT.
BUT AS THE DRONE LAUNCHES, IT
LURCHES THE WRONG WAY, HEADS FOR
TREES.
NOT CLEAR WHAT CAUSES THE
MALFUNCTION.
THERE IS A WAR WITHIN A WAR
HERE, A SOFTWARE DOGFIGHT IN THE
SKIES ABOVE THE BATTLEFIELD.
AND A MISTAKE BY THE DRONE
OPERATORS CAN COST THEM THEIR
LIVES.
BACK AT BASE, ON A BIG SCREEN,
THEY SCOUR THE FIRST FLIGHT'S
VIDEO.
DETAIL IS INCREDIBLE.
THE OPERATOR, A 24-YEAR-OLD
FORMER NEWS CAMERAMAN.
SO YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE
RUSSIANS BUT THEY CAN BE LOOKING
AT YOU WHEN YOU ARE IN THE
FIELD.
>> YES.
>> Reporter: HOW DOES THAT FEEL?
>> SCARY.
VERY SCARY.
>> Reporter: BUT YOU KEEP DOING
IT.
>> YEAH.
>> Reporter: WHY?
>> BECAUSE WE MUST DO IT.
>> Reporter: LIFE OR DEATH
DECISIONS WHICH STAR GETS THE
HIT TO SAVE HIS FELLOW
COUNTRYMEN.
HE HAS NO IDEA YOUR DRONE IS
FOLLOWING HIM.
>> NO IDEA.
>> Reporter: PREVIOUS DAYS WHEN
THEY HAVE AVOIDED RUSSIAN
COUNTERMEASURES THEY HAVE HAD
BETTER LUCK.
A RUSSIAN TANK POSITION HIT IN
THE PAST WEEK WHEN THEY CALLED
IN AN ARTILLERY STRIKE AS THEY
WATCHED.
WHO WINS DRONE WARS WILL HELP
DETERMINE WHO DOMINATES THE
BATTLE SPACE AND THAT DEPENDS ON
WHO HAS THE SMARTEST TECHNOLOGY.
AND WHO HAS THE BEST TRADITIONAL
FRONTLINE SKILLS TO HIDE FROM
IT.
NIC ROBERTSON, CNN, UKRAINE'S
SOUTHERN FRONT.